miss radler are the jurors coming in
all right thank you love your cup
thank you it's master's week your golfer
tiger gonna play or no i don't know i
hope so you do
not since hogan
it would be as big as his win two years
ago or three or whatever
this is fresh water by the way
so is that fresh water
yes it is yes thank you just be careful
when you pour it it comes out yeah
quickly you may want to get it yeah i've
seen this before
tell you it's a very strange experience
being here
i can imagine
jury answering
[Music]
all right bcd ladies and gentlemen sorry
for the delay i did conduct that 104
hearing with regard to the evidence and
the court to determine that the evidence
was not admissible
go ahead mr blancas
mr david uh
before we broke you indicated that
you have no recollection of discussing
laurent cataract tape recording michael
barriston for others during your meeting
correct that's correct
now
you called 911
you gave a statement to the morris
county prosecutor's office
on september 16 2019 do you recall that
i do
and
can i assume that you reviewed that with
the prosecutor no you cannot assume that
did you get a copy of it i did not
after you heard whatever you heard
on the telephone
did you make notes
of that conversation
well after the fact i was in a car when
it happened
so i did not take notes and
i didn't get back to my office till
later that day
and can i assume that later that day
after going through something like this
as a lawyer you wrote down everything
that you remembered
in case someone would want to question
you about this i know i did it i can't
tell you when
you can't tell me whether it was the
same day or some days after correct
it was within i might guess is
pure guess within 24 hours maybe 36
hours okay something i wouldn't forget
i mean
the whole thing lasted a minute or two
okay
well our conversation understand was was
uh
pretty one-sided and it happened over
the course of 10 or 15 seconds there
wasn't much to remember but i remember
writing down everything she said
everything i i could remember
so within 24 hours your best estimate
you write down everything that you
specifically recall with regards to this
conversation correct
yes
did you give those notes
to the prosecutor's office
i did
do you recall telling the prosecutor's
office in your official statement that
you destroyed
the original notes
no but i likely did
well i'm certain i did okay didn't you
just say
you gave those original notes to the
morris county prosecutor's office
no you just said that and i agreed
if you'd allow me to rephrase it i gave
them a copy of the notes the originals
understand my office is a green office i
don't keep
hard copies of anything as soon as i
have a document even one that i've
prepared i scan it into the computer and
destroy it
i don't have the capacity to keep 40
years of records
in an office so i do not keep an
original of anything
so
that is for all intents and purposes as
the courts of this state have recognized
appropriate
i'm going to show you d 1200 d okay
do you recognize that i do
are these
notes
that you
drafted regarding this incident
they are
are these the notes you just testified
you put down
approximately 24 hours or so after the
incident
yes
but i signed it apparently much later
when did you sign it
apparently much later
when did you sign it it is dated
september 16 2019. does that refresh
your recollection that you signed it on
on that day in september i just said i
did
but there's a reason for that well
if you'd like me to explain it i'm happy
to do that okay
what day did you give your statement to
the prosecutor's office don't recall
i show you
a copy of your statement d
1200 c
and ask you if this refreshes your
recollection as to when
you talk to the prosecutor regarding
this specific instance yes
okay and what day did you talk to the
prosecutor's office
september 16 2019 and that's why i
signed it this day
because i sent this to them i assume on
this date
but i scanned it into my computer and i
could probably dig up the date of the
scan
at around the time that i wrote it
because that is what i do 100
of the time
i take notes i scan it into my computer
i didn't think i had to date the notes
but when i spoke to the prosecutor's
office and they wanted a copy of it i
signed it i dated it
and i put the time
you put that down sure
that's what i required
[Music]
now
prior to this incident you had
a number of conversations with michael
barrasson's lawyer stephen tarchesis
correct prior to when
prior to the shooting yes
and
was it your impression that
he and you were in the process of
working out lauren cataract leaving the
property
we were working out a settlement of the
the um
dispute
uh one of the issues that we needed to
resolve was if and when lauren would
leave the property yeah
you also mentioned something about
facebook posts
prior to that meeting had you received
some of warren cataract's facebook posts
did you again object that this is beyond
the scope of the direct examination
it is somewhat beyond the scope mr
blancas
now on the day of the
incident
did you call rob
goodwin or did he call you
i believe i called him
do you recall telling the police in your
official statement that you're
not sure
whether
you reached out to lauren
or whether rob called you
i don't specifically recall that but
understand
i was in somewhat of a
in extremis i had just been on the
telephone when i heard gunshots and my
client telling me she's been shot in the
chest i wasn't exactly focusing on who
called whom
at that very moment well you were
very
definitive in court today
with regards to who called who correct
correct and would you agree with me on
page 7
of the transcript
yeah i either reached out to lauren or
rob called me yeah okay okay well that's
different than your definitive answer
that you gave on correct well i would
assume you'd have the copies of the
telephone records that would determine
who called whom
right i mean how hard is that to get
not at all but okay
all right hold on a second getting a
little argumentative here
just answer the questions if there's any
follow-up mr shellhorn can ask you
questions i have thought about it and of
course i called rob
so if i said
at this moment when i was in extremis
that i didn't recall whether i called
him or he called her that wasn't the
first thing on my mind the first thing
on my mind was reporting that my
client's been shot by your client
so
that's what really was important to me
at that moment not who called whom okay
do you remember telling the prosecutor
that
i think i reached out to him but i
couldn't swear correct uh i don't recall
that
if it's in the transcript i assume i
said it
again
in extremis
right now
irrespective of who called who
you're talking to rob goodwin correct
correct
and what did you say to rob goodman rob
can i speak to lauren
and lauren's the one who's in control of
everything correct based on your i don't
know what that means
lauren was my client
so i was calling to speak to lauren
did you say to the prosecutor's office
words to effect that if you get to know
rob you'll know that lauren was the one
who actually was really handling this
did you make a statement like that i
certainly could have lauren was going to
make the decision she was my client
you're talking to rob
and
at what point at what point
when you first
got on the phone you were talking to rob
goodman correct
i said four words to him okay
and then the phone
was put in lauren's hand correct correct
do you recall rob yelling
in the background
or speaking loudly either one
specifically no
i asked you to turn to page nine
the sixth egg
from the top
can you read it and see if that
refreshes your recollection
as to after
you were talking to lawrence canara you
heard rob yelling in the background or
talking loudly
yeah i i see that
and then could you go down one two three
more edge
and then did you say
or do you recall straight down yeah
you're refreshing his recollection
do you recall
hearing a gunshot at that point
i recall
hearing a gunshot after lauren
or michael it could have been michael
said
there is barrister michael um robert i'm
sorry
saying there's um
there's barrisone
because i was calling to speak to lauren
to tell her we had made headway
um
in the resolution it was it was supposed
to be a good phone call
and and
the next thing i knew
oh my god
i've been shot in the heart something
like that okay but again before the
shooting
isn't it a fact that in your original
statement you told the prosecutor
that
you heard rob in the background
yelling or speaking loudly before the
shot
okay yeah i mean that's what it says so
i assume i said it and at some point in
time then you say or strike that
is it at that point that you heard
what you now know
is a gunshot
um
yeah
and what do you mean by
what i now know
was a gunshot
well
when i heard it
as
i'm sure anybody can imagine i i am not
familiar with gunshots at all
i heard what i thought was a gunshot and
lauren's saying oh my god i've been shot
in the heart
but you kind of don't believe it
how could that how could that possibly
be
i've since learned of course you know
a few hours later that it was
a gun shot and who told you that
maybe the washington township police
department
did you have a discussion with them with
regards to this incident
i was trying to get somebody on the
phone it actually may have been and i
no recollection of who told me but i
reached out to john and kirby counteract
lauren's parents i reached out to
the washington township police
department
and did all these people tell you that
lauren cataract had been shot
somebody told me that lauren canaric had
been shot i don't know if all of them
told me i know i spoke to all of them at
some point within that that gestalt
but i don't couldn't tell you
um definitively
um
who told me that lauren actually had
been shot do you recall telling the
prosecutor's office that when you heard
whatever you heard
you didn't think gunshot
no that i i
i don't recall saying it but i'm certain
that that's what happened because you
don't believe gunshot i'm driving up 280
trying to speak to my client that's all
so so imagine how out of outer worldly
it would be
to hear what you think are gunshots
but you just don't believe it and i just
didn't you know you don't want to
believe it but i believed it enough
to call 9-1-1 right away so something
inside me must have said to yourself
this could be real or
either that
and correct me a firmware or lauren
canarax saying that she was shot
well we know lauren was shot so how do
you know lauren is shot at that point
at that very moment because she told me
she was shot okay and did you tell the
prosecutor that you did not think
gunshot
when you gave your statement yes or no
i can't answer that question yes or no
can you refer to page
nine of the transcript
the second ed from the
bottom and tell me whether that
refreshes your recollection with regards
to whether you told the morris county
prosecutor's office
that after you heard
rob goodwin yelling
you hear something but you don't think
gunshots
as i explained to you before
when something so out of context occurs
you don't immediately go to something
that
in your wildest imagination could occur
right if it if if it has stripes and
hooves you think zebra
right
i wasn't thinking gunshot there there
was no reason to think gunshot but
obviously i must have because i called
9-1-1
do you recall telling anyone that
the noise that you heard sounded like
something heavy dropping no
i don't think i ever told anybody that
at that point
after you hear
whatever you hear
did you say the phone dropped at that
point
yes
and was that immediately after you
hearing whatever you heard no
when was
that maybe 10 seconds later
after she said i've been shot in the
heart something to words to that effect
then i'm saying lauren what's going on
what's up hello hello i heard what i
thought was the phone dropping okay and
and that's approximately 10
seconds
after you hear what you hear correct
10 15 seconds yeah and at that point you
hear scuffling correct yes
but then i hung up
at some point in time after
you believed you heard the phone drop
did you hear someone pick up the phone
call
when you look at page 10
the last ad on the body
page 10
yeah oh so that's how it happened okay
that's possible so can you say let me
ask you yeah
you say
you heard what you thought the phone
dropped correct
yes now this refreshed my recollection
at some point in time
did someone pick up that phone
i said here the phone must have been
picked up okay now let me ask you a
question
that was
after you heard whatever sound you heard
correct
yes
that's for sure i heard the sound first
is that one
at that point
lauren counteract makes the statements
she gave to you okay yes and you were
incorrect on your previous i i stand
corrected yes
gotta understand this was four years ago
and i haven't looked at this in four
years
and after lauren cataract
makes the statements
strike that did she say i'm losing
consciousness
she might have
can you look on page 11
four edge from the bottom and see if
that refreshes your recollection as to
whether one of the things that lauren
cataract said to you is i'm losing
consciousness
yes
yeah it does refresh my my right and you
recall her saying that correct yes
did the phone drop again
after that statement
well i i think so
because
at some point i realized she wasn't on
the other end of the phone any longer
and that's when i disconnected the call
and
call i believe i called her back
or called rob's phone again
um
right away
and uh
didn't there was nobody who picked up
and that's when i did i guess i pulled
over and decided to call 911
now
based on your
meetings
meeting or contact with lauren panoramic
did you get the impression that she
wasn't afraid of michael barrasson
no i i got the impression she was very
afraid of michael barrasso can you
please turn to page
15
the fifth bed from the top
and see if that represses your
recollection as to whether or not you
got the impression that lauren conrad
was not afraid of michael barrasson
i'm on page 15 please just direct me to
where you want me to go two three four
five eggs from the top
oh at that very moment yes i got the
yeah
you know you put that out of context
lauren was afraid of michael barrasson
at the at this particular period of time
after speaking with mr tarshish
and and really making a significant
headway in resolving this whole thing
and de-escalating the situation
yeah i i
think lauren was not afraid of him at
all not at that very moment no
right before the shooting right before
the shooting
because the whole thing was being
resolved i when you say the whole thing
was going to be resolved
you would never talk to lauren cataract
prior to the shooting with respect to
your conversations with tarshists
regarding resolving this case correct
i don't recall isn't it isn't the fact
that you called them on that day to
reprise him of your conversation with
tarshish i had called them on that day
to apprise her of where we were at that
particular moment in time i had been on
the phone with tarshish
since the day before
trying to resolve this
now
prior to this day
did you get the impression that the
issues between barristone and cataract
had been going on for
weeks if not longer
did i have that impression yes
now would you agree that
what you were hearing traumatized you
yes
and would you agree that
that could have an impact on your
recollection of events correct
no
incorrect
the fact that i heard gunshots is
immutable
i heard gunshots the fact that lauren
said i've been shot in the chest is
immutable i heard that and it happened
no amount of trauma is going to change
that
there are things that
which you reminded me of there were
other things that that happened
that i now recollect
but i will never ever forget
that moment in time
just looking through my notes if i could
judge have a second i believe i'm almost
done
did you have the impression that uh
michael barrisson's girlfriend was uh
creating issues
with cataract embarrassment
i was
i was informed that that was the case
prior to
the shooting
two points your honor
thank you church
good mayor approach the witness
sure
mr david for the record that spin mark
is s-442
directing your attention to lines
uh eight i believe it's lines eight and
nine
do you see a phone number on those lines
yes and i'm not going to ask you to put
your phone number on the record i would
not do that but is that your phone
number yes it is and does that
your cell phone
does that indicate uh whether or not and
without telling us whether or not there
was an incoming call or an outgoing call
related to that number
i'm sorry without telling you whether it
was an incoming or outcome just to look
at it to refresh your memory yes it
refreshes my memory does that refresh
your memory or does that confirm to you
whether or not you made the call to mr
goodwin or you received the call 100
i i made that call
i made one two calls
actually three calls which makes perfect
sense
and can you explain to the jury and i'll
just take this back what your
recollection is about the three calls
that you made
the first call which appears to be four
minutes
um
was my call to rob to
tell lauren
um
what's going on in the case and my
discussions with tarshish and when she
got shot and
whatever
the second call was after i disconnected
the first call to see if she was okay
and my recollection is she didn't or rob
didn't pick up
um and then i did it again because you
know
you just keep on calling until
until you're sure somebody picks up or
you're sure somebody's not going to pick
up and i guess after that call
after the third call
is when i called 9-1-1
now you were asked a question about the
handwritten notes that i think were
marked as d
1200d
when you had actually
written those notes to yourself or
written down what you recalled yes and i
think your answer on cross-examination
was that you thought it might have been
sometime in that first 24 hours or no
more than 24 hours yes
i'm going to direct your attention and i
don't know if you still have it in front
of you i have no script yeah i have
nothing in front of you
yes
[Music]
yep
specifically on page 21 if you look uh
approximately halfway down the page or
so
yes where i believe that the detective
asked uh you were kind enough to give us
a copy of your report yeah of your notes
rather yes does that refresh your memory
reading that about approximately when
you wrote the notes down
respected to the the incident occurring
yes and it it
jives with what i've been saying
i got back to my office i wrote down the
notes it's my practice i do it 100
percent of the time not 99 100 of the
time i write down contemporaneous notes
scan them and
i believe throughout the original this
one i may have kept i may not have i
don't have it i don't know if i gave it
to
to somebody from the prosecutor's office
i don't know and approximately how far
after the incident occurring did you
write those notes down to yourself
within an hour
i mean right away i signed it i i signed
it i believe when we met
when i met with the investigator
judge no further questions
you may step down thank you sir thank
you
should i leave this here yes please
thank you sir
mr shellhorn you're under subject to
moving evidence in state rest
all right very good
all right ladies and gentlemen the state
has rested their case subject to moving
in some evidence which we're going to
address right now
um during at least part of the lunch and
recess
and then we'll begin the defense case in
the afternoon so
enjoy your lunch we're a little bit
early but you can take until uh 1 30 or
so and we'll hopefully have all the
legal issues resolved and we'll begin
the defense case then
all right thank you please don't discuss
the case during your lunch and recess
[Music]
on the record